I had dinner between the
last video and this one.
So I might have forgotten
what I just did.
I think I was about to-- if
what I see on my board makes
sense-- I was about to use the
Taylor series, or in this
specific example the Maclaurin
series approximation, to figure
out a polynomial version, a sum
of polynomial terms to
approximate e to the x.
And remember let me write
here what the definition of
the Maclaurin series was.
That we said that f of x is
equal to the sum from n equals
0 to infinite of the nth
derivative of f evaluated at
0-- I don't know if I
remembered to put it evaluated
at 0 last time I wrote this
down-- times x to the
n over n factorial.
And hopefully that
makes sense to you.
This might seem really
confusing and strange.
But now that we're going to
apply it to e to the x, this
should maybe be a little
bit more concrete.
And I think at the end of the
last video I said that if f of
x is e to the x, f of 0 is
e to the 0, which is 1.
And f prime of x, any
derivative of e to the x
is equal to e to the x.
So you take any derivative of
at 0, and it equals 1 for e to
the x for this particular
case of f of x.
And that's really neat.
That means that the rate of
change of y with respect to x
is for every 1 you move in x,
you move 1 in y at e to the 0.
But that also means that
the rate of change of the
rate of change is also 1.
At the rate of change at
the rate of change at the
rate of change is also 1.
So at either the 0 or x equals
0 of e to the x, the slope of
the slope of the slope of the
slope of the slope of the slope
of the slope, they're all 1.
Which to me tells me something
mysterious is happening.
It's another reason why you
should just sit and ponder e.
But anyway, back to what
we were trying to do.
So how would we do this?
How would be write
the approximation?
Let me write the approximate.
I'll call that p of x.
Because it's going
to be a polynomial.
Well in this particular case,
what's the derivative of any
derivative evaluated at f of 0?
Well that term is 1.
We wrote that down right here.
f of 0 is 1.
The first derivative at 0 is 1.
The second derivative
at 0 is 1.
Right?
That's what's special
about e to the x.
So all of these terms
are going to equal 1.
So this polynomial simplifies
to the sum from n equals 0 to
infinite of x to the
n over n factorial.
That to me is very neat.
Remember these are
all 1 in every term.
So that's why I took it out.
So what does that mean?
Well that tells us that e to
the x can be approximated.
And actually, I don't
prove it here.
But it actually turns out that
we take the infinite sum that
the Maclaurin series not only
approximates e to the
x at x equals 0.
When you take the infinite
series, it actually
equals e to the x.
So when you take a Maclaurin
series at 0, and the resulting
function, the resulting
polynomial actually converges--
and that's something we'll
learn a little bit more
rigorously hopefully later when
we start doing analysis-- but
it can actually converge to the
function at all points.
And it actually is the
case with e to the x.
So we can actually say
that e to the x is equal.
I didn't prove this.
But you can take
my word for it.
And you can even test it
out with some numbers.
It equals this sum.
Well what is this sum?
It's x to the 0 over 0
factorial plus x to the 1 over
1 factorial plus x-squared
over 2 factorial.
And you keep going.
Of course that's equal.
So e to x is equal
to-- x to the 0 is 1.
0 factorial, I said in
the last video is 1.
So it's 1 plus this is just x,
plus x-squared over 2 factorial
plus x to the third over
3 factorial plus x to the
fourth over 4 factorial.
And you just keep
going on forever.
And that's e to the x.
And to me that is amazing.
Because this strange number e,
this 2.7 whatever, whatever,
that we got from compound
interest, it can be written as
an infinite polynomial, this
polynomial series or this
Maclaurin series, that actually
has a certain beauty to it.
This number is kind of ugly
when you write it out,
2.7 whatever, whatever.
But when you write it to an
exponent power as an infinite
sum, it kind of has
a nice rhythm to it.
It's very patterned.
Who would have guessed that
you could have written it
in such a simple form.
And even more, what happens
when x is equal to 1.
Right?
So what's e to the 1?
Well then we set x equal
to 1 on both sides.
And I think I have space to
do it here, e to the 1,
which is equal to e.
We just set all the x's to 1.
So we get that's equal to 1
plus 1 plus 1 over 2 factorial
plus 1 over 3 factorial plus 1
over 4 factorial plus
1 over 5 factorial.
That to me, once
again, is amazing.
That the number e, and we've
just stumbled on another
definition of e, e is equal to
the sum from n equals 0 to
infinite of 1 over n factorial.
That is amazing.
So now we have two
definitions for e.
We have this one that we
stumbled on, and of course we
had the ones from compound
interest that I will
do in magenta.
The limit as n approaches
infinite, 1 plus 1
over n to the n.
That also is equal to e.
This is starting to
give me chills.
Because this very strange,
bizarre number is popping out.
This might not seem
so natural to you.
But it's neat.
And it comes out in compound
interest, and continuously
compounding interest.
But this is even simpler.
I just keep picking one over
the factorial of numbers and
I add them all together.
And if I take every number
really in existence, and I
sum them all up, I get e.
That to me is amazing.
1 over n factorial of
essentially every integer
from 0 to infinite.
If I sum them up, I
get the number e.
You hopefully are getting
chills right now.
Well anyway, let's do the
Maclaurin series for a
couple more functions.
And then we'll get to something
that is even more mind-blowing.
I'll see you in the next video.